Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
The promise of virtual reality, VR is indeed
truly incredible.
If one day it comes to fruition, doctors could
be trained to perform surgery in a virtual
environment, we could train better pilots
with better flight simulators, expose astronauts
to virtual zero-gravity simulations, you name
it.
This previous work uses a learning-based algorithm
to teach a head-mounted camera to tell the
orientation of our hands at all times.
Okay, so what can we do with this?
A great deal.
For instance, we can type on a virtual keyboard,
or implement all kinds of virtual user interfaces
that we can interact with.
We can also organize imaginary boxes, and
of course, we can’t leave out the the Two
Minute Papers favorite, going into a physics
simulation and playing with it with our own
hands.
But of course, not everything is perfect here,
however.
Look.
Hand-hand interactions don’t work so well,
so folks who prefer virtual reality applications
that include washing our hands should look
elsewhere.
And in this series, we often say “one more
paper down the line, and it will be significantly
better”.
So now, here is the moment of truth, let’s
see that one more paper down the line.
Let’s go in guns blazing and give it examples
with challenging hand-hand interactions, deformations,
lots of self-contact and self-occlusion.
Take a look at this footage.
This seems like a nightmare for any hand reconstruction
algorithm.
Who the heck can solve this?
And, look, interestingly, they also recorded
the hand model with gloves on.
How curious!
And now, hold on to your papers because these
are not gloves…no, no, no.
What you see here is the reconstruction of
the hand model by a new algorithm.
Look.
It can deal with all of these rapid hand motions.
And what’s more, it also works on this challenging
hand massage scene.
Look at all those beautiful details!
It not only fits like a glove here too, but
I see creases, folds, and deformations too
- this reconstruction is truly out of this
world.
To be able to do this, the algorithm has to
output triangle meshes that typically contain
over a hundred thousand faces.
Please remember this as we will talk about
it later.
And now, let’s see how it does all this
magic, because there is plenty of magic under
the hood.
Let’s look at the five ingredients that
are paramount to getting an output of this
quality.
Ingredient number one is the physics term.
Without it, we can’t even dream of tracking
self-occlusion and contact properly.
Two, since there are plenty of deformations
going on in the input footage, the deformation
term accounts for that.
It makes a huge difference in the reconstruction
of the thumb here.
And if you think “wow, that is horrific”,
then you’ll need to hold on to your papers
for the next one, which is…three…the geometric
consistency term.
This one is not for the faint of the heart.
You have been warned.
Are you ready?
Let’s go.
Yikes!
A piece of advice, if you decide to implement
this technique, make sure to include this
geometric consistency term so no one has to
see this footage ever again.
Thank you.
With the worst already behind us, let’s
proceed to ingredient number four, the photo-consistency
term.
This ensures that fingernail tips don’t
end up sliding into the finger.
And five, the collision term fixes problems
like this to make sure that the fingers don’t
penetrate each other.
And this is an excellent paper, so in the
evaluation section, these terms are also tested
in isolation, and the authors tell us exactly
how much each of these ingredients contribute
to the solution.
Now, these five ingredients are not cheap
in terms of computation time, and remember,
we also mentioned that many of these meshes
have several hundred thousand faces.
This means that this technique takes a very
long time to compute all this.
It is not real time, not even close, for instance,
reconstructing the mesh for the hand massage
scene takes more than 10 minutes per frame.
This means hours, or even days of computation
to accomplish this.
Now the question naturally arises - is that
a problem?
No, not in the slightest.
This is a zero to one paper, which means that
it takes a problem that was previously impossible,
and now, it makes it possible.
That is absolutely amazing.
And as always, research is a process, and
this is an important stepping stone in this
process.
I bet that two more good papers down the line,
and we will be getting these gloves interactively.
I am so happy about this solution, as it could
finally give us new ways interact with each
other in virtual spaces, add more realism
to digital characters, help us better understand
human-human interactions, and it may also
enable new applications in physical rehabilitation.
And these reconstructions indeed fit like
a glove.
What a time
to
be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!